the Joe Rogan experience they sure will
Al's read everything I said it's not an
owl flying with a rabbit a big-ass
rabbit in its claws once they're so
vicious yeah and there's such scary
hunters like I know at night and head
spins around have you ever seen that
video there's a nest video of these
Hawks that are in a tree and this owl
comes out and snatches one of the Hawks
and flies away and you just from a
distance they're like what is that
right when you you're talking about the
one with the eyeballs yeah and then also
like what any good BAM that's just gone
yeah yeah they're [ __ ] monsters
freaky animals man and we we think of
him as being these wise like like it's
professors of the woods for some strange
reason have you ever heard Matt Braunger
zal bit no it is one of the funniest
things isn't really yeah this is like
the bit that he first like his early on
you know getting his is a first big joke
that broke and you know it was on
Letterman and he was on Comedy Central
it is a hug layer I got to see it I got
to see it as owls are one of those weird
animals that we have this very strange
relationship with well we don't know
what they really are yeah this distort
bears or another one we have this
distorted perception with it did you see
that video that was going around about
that guy who got his face literally
eaten off by a grizzly and then he shot
the grizzly when it was on top of him no
oh dude have you seen it Jamie yeah he's
talking he's like going around good yeah
yeah he's talking while his face is gone
and he's talking about like you could
see one eye through this mass I mean if
Jamie shakes his head like let me show
it to you real quick
yeah of his face - no it's right after
the attack the guard that was with him
started filming it and it's just one of
those things where okay so this is the
bear and this is the guy and that's his
face and this is him talking where are
you where are you seeing this
mr. Graham
yes bro
the thing Chu is face off that's him
nasty looks like now [ __ ] they rebuilt
his face that's incredible
did you have a doctor well you saw the
chimp victim lady yeah her face is gone
well that chimp worked on her for a
while did you see the tree trimming it
go go lower there Jamie galore yeah
scroll down whoa what tree trimming what
what you've never seen that we're
talking about dude and there's and you
get to see the live oh where the tree
goes into the guy's face this whole
[ __ ] yeah it wide open
yes and then they show him in the
hospital yeah you can see even in his
completely destroyed face the panic and
it's like he knows how serious his
situation is yeah I mean they were able
don't know I haven't seen the
post-surgery stuff but that dude a tree
just like perfect he cut he was trimming
and like he just cut it and it didn't
circle and split his whole [ __ ] face
yeah oh my god yeah it's rough man
yeah that's a rough look right there
that's a rough look it's amazing how
well they put that guy back together if
I was him I would just be the Punisher
for grizzly bears
I just just load up every year with a
million rounds of ammo I just go hunting
bears [ __ ] you have you hunted a bear
you know yeah black bears not not
grizzly bears yeah yeah we don't we have
this image of them because it teddy
bears because kids have them you know
they love them little teddy bears are
the biggest right if you have polar
bears brown bears and then yeah yeah
yeah cuz I mean a brown bear can stand
up and be what like 9 feet taller bigger
11 really yeah Kodiak the really big one
hey Cody in a swipe just a potato
my friend watched a bear kill a moose
with one SWAT broke its back he watch to
chase this moose through a scope was
looking at through a spotting scope
which is like like a super powerful
you could look at you know like at my
mile away you can watch things happen
and this bear just SWAT hit this moose
in the back and snapped its back power
you have to snap a mooses back oh my god
I just tore it apart
I mean how powerful is that animal it's
a big [ __ ] animal man you know you're
talking about a 1,500 pound just ball a
muscle and fat
[Applause]